[Musique]
oh [__] qu'est ce qu'on a fait encore
là j'ai moi je sois là souviens juste
c'est quoi cette voie là ouais c'est pas
j'ai dû trop gueuler à bon dieu je me
souviens juste du début quoi salut mec
saluer gabin rentrée en fait on va se
mettre bien
une halte fluviale à royan robin qui
devrait pas tarder à bien au fond les
gars ouais mais tu découvres je suis
débile
[Musique]
c'est vraiment dégueulasse
après c'est le black out je trouve c'est
pas nous qui avons fait ça mais comme un
pétard bon coeur un char tu peux checker
nous souvenir parce que c'est flou en
fait ok je fais non rien du tout
[Musique]
suite
même en famille
roj
[Musique]
et
à
[Musique]
moi ou les cas légal égard un grand
pouvoir implique de nick travaille
[Musique]
non c'est super les gardes des soins
avec niveau son show maksat afin de
contester c'est pas ta km sa batterie
[Musique]
a souffert
l'epa marquent et loire essentielles sur
quatre aux éleveurs
[Musique]
voir
et là ça s'énerve
il a dit
au passé exactement qui est derrière
tout ça ah ben ça c'est 1,5 ou du joker
c'est le joker
lex luthor le bouffon vert magnéto enfin
tous les connards ceux qui ont fait ça
[Musique]
et ça le [__] ce que signifie ce
symbole sur la lune encore une énigme
oui oui oui c'est une énigme et on s'en
va
tafer dessus là on est tous un peu la
ville mais on est inconscient de
récupérer
oui madame suzanne oui je sais mais
c'est la dernière fois promis oui je
sais que l'état des lieux c'est demain
je sais mais là je suis à l'étranger en
fait bien encore une fois je suis désolé
un halo
[Musique]